Let's think about it for a little bit, you'll see there is really only two possibilities.
If we're trying to find the shortest path from I to J that is allowed to use K
and any of the nodes with numbers smaller than K.
There are two possibilities. It may be that we don't need to use K at all for the smallest path.
We just follow path from I to J only using nodes who have values less than K
or we go and visit K and then we go from K to J,
but in visiting K, we don't ever need to visit K on the way to K that wouldn't be a very good path.
The shortest path from I to K only using nodes that are less than K
then we follow another path now from K to J only using nodes whose numbers are less than K.
Those are the only things that could happen. We don't want to visit K twice.
We're not allowed to use any nodes that are greater than K
those are the two possibilities and whichever one of these two things is shortest.
The shortest path from I to K followed by the shortest path from K to J
or the shortest path from I to J whichever those two things are shortest,
is the shortest path from I to J possibly using K and things less than K.
We can just write that in a straightforward way
by taking advantage of the fact that someone has given us the K,
not tooth decay but matrix decay.
The length of the shortest path from I to K using only those less than K, we have that already.
Someone gave it to us very helpfully.
All we need to do is compare the distance of I to J not using K
and the distance from I to K not using K and K to J not using K.
It's weird, but it's the right thing to do.
We can take advantage of this insight to actually create an efficient algorithm
We can initialize D⁰ so this is the length of the shortest path from I to J
using nodes only numbered less than zero which is to say no intermediate node,
but that's just the direct cost of going from I to J.
>From the cost in our graph, we can fill in this matrix.
And once we have D⁰ initialize, we can run K from 0 to n-1
and for each pair of I and J, take Dk+1 to be the smaller of D⁰[k,i,,j]
and D⁰[k,i,k} and D⁰[k,i,j] add it together just as I was describing before.
When this is all over, when this loop is done, we have the D⁰n,
but D⁰[n,i,j} is the length of the shortest from I to J
only hopping on nodes that are numbered less than n, but that's all the nodes.
All the nodes are numbered less than n.
They are all numbered from 0 to n-1.
so this is the length of the shortest path from I to J, unrestricted, full stop.
so that's pretty cool, and if you think about what's going on here,
this initialization step runs over all pairs of nodes so that's n².
This loop runs over all pairs of nodes n², but it does this from each value from 0 to n-1.
So altogether we're talking about n*n² or n³.
This better than the n3/logn we get by applying repeat Dijkstra to a dense graph.
So for a dense graph, you're better off using Floyd-Warshall n³ instead of the n³/logn.
Log n is often not that huge a number so your mileage may vary.
so you can actually try the overhead, but boy it's hard to imagine having less overhead than this
It is very straightforward it runs through the n³ possibilities,
and in fact, if we do this carefully, we don't need to keep a separate D matrix for each of this cases.
You can actually do these updates completely in place so the storage is pretty low too.